today on the matt walsh show teachers
around the country are claiming that
going back to school would be a death
sentence for them yet many of them are
out protesting in large crowds it's
almost as if
their fear of returning to work is
performative and fake i don't know
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including speaking of teachers
a teacher who specializes in helping
children with emotional needs now
arrested for assaulting a state senator
at a protest
so i think maybe she has some emotional
needs of her own
and our daily cancellation we will
cancel everyone who is claiming
that police arresting suspects
are kidnapping them so all of that on
the way but first
a word from ready wise you know as you
probably already know
our sponsor wise company has changed
their name to ready-wise and ready-wise
is all about being ready being prepared
being wise as their name suggests in
case of an emergency
look um now is uh is there's never gonna
be a better time than now to to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options ready wise has options like
emergency meals uh freeze-dried fruits
and vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
other outdoor activities so it's not
just emergencies it's also
if you're out in nature i've i've used
the uh the adventure meals myself and
uh they're very convenient and delicious
ready-wise meals are easy to prepare and
have a very long shelf life as far as
preparing it's so simple that
you know even i can do it all you have
to do is add water it really is that
easy ready wise makes
being prepared simple and affordable you
can order online you can have nutritious
meals shipped directly to
your doorstep and one last important
point here maybe most important of all
for me readywise uses the finest
ingredients and latest
food preparation technology so that
means that you're getting a good taste
too you don't have to sacrifice
just because you have the convenience
and it's something that you're using for
an emergency
it doesn't mean you have to sacrifice
taste each meal is a combination of both
dehydrated and freeze-dried ingredients
uh meals are packed into durable
long-lasting pouches designed to keep
food fresh
for up to 25 years so you're going to
want to take advantage of this
so listen this week my listeners can get
free shipping at readywise.com
when entering walsh at checkout or by
calling 855-475-3089
readywise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
ready wise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code welsh to get free
shipping
go there now readywise.com okay now
this week uh public school teachers in
dc who
you understand care for nothing as much
as educating the children and equipping
the new generation with
the tools they need to succeed in life
that's what we're told about teachers
that's all they care about
um but they protested the plan to
possibly reopen schools in the fall by
placing
fake body bags outside of the school
district's office
striking a you know a careful balance
between absurd mellow drama
and shameless self-aggrandizement one of
the bags was accompanied by you can see
here
a cardboard gravestone that said r.i.p
favorite teacher
then you can see the others they read
killed in the line of duty
how many will you let die this is
teachers across the country have been
engaging in these kinds of theatrics for
weeks now a recent cnn article
says that educators are preparing their
wills in anticipation of going back to
work
which going back to work is an act
apparently tantamount to being sent to
death row in fact a recent article on a
website for educators called board
teacher
which i guess i know why they're bored
they're not working claims outright that
reopening schools is a quote
death sentence for teachers which seems
to be the general sentiment expressed by
many of the
hundreds of teachers who have taken to
the streets to protest the reopening of
schools
now one can't help but wonder
why these teachers who seem who see the
classroom as some kind of
death chamber apparently have no concern
about protesting in large groups
you know we should note that teachers
have also had a notable presence
at the blm protests and the riots for
the past several weeks in portland
they've even formed a formed a group
called teachers against
tyrants because again they have nothing
better to do and they've been wading
into the non-socially distanced
mass of people to convey that political
message in philadelphia
teachers gathered with their students to
march for black lives matter
similar scenes have unfolded other
places texas austin texas they've been
out with their students as well
if teaching in front of a classroom of
children is a death sentence
what about standing in an enormous crowd
of other adults
isn't that a death sentence now in
reality of course
neither a protest nor a classroom is a
death sentence or anything close to it
the average age of a public school
teacher in america is 41
putting most of them well outside of the
high risk age bracket
they're also working closely with
children a group that happens to be
least at risk of contracting spreading
or developing serious complications from
the virus
so it's not that teaching carries no
covet risk at all but that the risk is
far less significant
than what we're being told and what
they're pretending and whatever the risk
it's hard to see how it would be
substantially greater than the risk of
attending a raucous protest
with thousands of other adults meanwhile
grocery stores walmarts many other
retailers have been open throughout the
pandemic even at its height they were
open
now it's possible that i missed it but i
don't recall the collective voice of our
nation's teachers
crying out for target to be closed for
the sake of its workers
in fact i would guess that a fair number
of these people who are allegedly so
petrified of returning to the classroom
have themselves been patronizing retail
establishments and grocery stores
this entire time and it's not just
teachers i don't remember hearing
almost anyone demand that these places
be closed
if we're supposed to weep for the fate
of our doomed teachers
why not kroger cashiers what about them
now i'll be told that all of this is
very different from the situation
teachers
will be in when they return to school
school is indoors
it lasts for several hours many students
are
confined to one classroom all of that
now it's true that
those factors present unique challenges
but
there are also unique advantages namely
as i already outlined
the fact that kids are statistically
unlikely to contract or spread the virus
teachers will be spending most of their
time therefore
with the safest the safest group of
people to be around at least as far as
covet is concerned so this is one of the
reasons by the way that the american
academy of pediatrics
recommends that schools be reopened in
the fall okay these are pediatricians
saying we have to reopen schools
but the main thing that ought to
balance out the challenges and prompt
any dedicated and good teacher
to call for a return to class is the
overwhelming importance
of education this after all is the
actual reason
why few people complained about grocery
stores and retail outlets
remaining open we all believe those
establishments
are essential to the proper functioning
of society that's why we were fine
with them being open don't we just say
the same only more
so for education now i've already argued
on a previous show that as far as i'm
concerned public school teachers
can and probably in most cases should be
replaced by parents
as a homeschool advocate i don't think
that public school is essential but most
of the people
protesting the reopening of schools
would disagree
it's they who would say in any other
circumstance
that kids need school and will be
gravely harmed without it
so isn't that enough reason to reopen
the schools
putting everything else aside shouldn't
the fact that our children
allegedly need the public school system
be sufficient justification for getting
them open again
isn't that all we need to say if you
really care about the kids it's clear
that that
the the move to keep schools closed has
less to do with precaution
than with priority education is not as
important to some of these teachers as
they used to pretend
they will risk their lives to send a
political message at a protest
or to shop at target but not to teach
our kids
children have to take a back seat but if
there is one good thing to come out of
all of this i think
what we're seeing now with teachers all
over the country putting politics before
their students and demanding that
schools
remain closed indefinitely education be
damned
what we're seeing really is the official
and final death
of the hero teacher narrative because
for a long time teachers were
put forth as an untouchable group
saints martyrs heroes above criticism
the teachers unions have worked very
hard to construct and defend this false
narrative and inculcate society into it
it was never true of course i mean no
group is above criticism least of all
government employees
and given that these government
employees work with our children and are
entrusted with so much authority
over our children it is absolutely
essential that we keep a critical eye
trained
on them and that we're ready to hold
them accountable it's extremely
dangerous for teachers of all people
teachers to be seen as above criticism
and this becomes even more the case when
you consider that these government
employees who spend eight hours a day
with our kids
and have enormous influence over our
kids also happen to be overwhelmingly
aligned with one political ideology
so just to give you an idea of how
strikingly disproportionate this is
let me read a little bit from an article
on the pacific research institute's
website here's what it says
uh this might not surprise you it
doesn't surprise you that they're biased
but it might surprise you to see just
how unbalanced it is
the washington post this is the pacific
research institute says the washington
post
reported on research conducted by
verdant labs using political
contribution data on the democrat
republican divide
based on job type while it is
unsurprising that among actors and
actresses there are 90 democrats for
every 10 republicans
many would be amazed to discover that
teachers are actually as liberal or even
more so than those in acting
among english teachers there are 97
democrats for every three republicans
with the proportion being even more
one-sided among health teachers
with 99 democrats for every one
republican
99 to 1. while there are slightly more
republicans among math and science
teachers the article continues and says
among high school
teachers overall there are 87 democrats
for every 13 republicans
87 to 13 overall
okay now just because a teacher has a
certain political leaning that doesn't
mean
they're going to overtly attempt to
indoctrinate children into it but
many do overtly and many others
uh do so not as overly perhaps not even
consciously but they still do it
my point here is simply that for the
sake of our kids this is a profession we
should be watching very closely like a
hawk very critically
many teachers are good at their jobs and
and really do care for their kids and
are wonderful people
i had some teachers like that as a kid
but other teachers are
let's face it political hacks
highly ideological in their approach
selfish
ill-equipped incompetent dishonest and
this group has been making itself
especially known this summer
and this is all something we should keep
in mind for the future
um one final point okay i just want to
mention this too because i know it's
going to come up
it will be argued that it's okay to
close schools
because we could just teach kids online
right we don't even need to
schools to be open um this is false and
it's coming from people remember who
under any other circumstance
would say that the actual in-person
experience of school is essential to a
child's development
we homeschoolers have been hearing this
socialization line for decades we
you know we have to send our kids to
school to be properly socialized
now once again i disagree with that
claim but the people who made that claim
should agree with it which means they
shouldn't be saying that now school
could be replaced with a computer screen
and we're not going to lose anything in
the train in translation
but even aside from the social aspect do
you really think that a nine-year-old
kid
can be effectively taught via zoom
meeting or skype chat
no the idea is absurd it's hard enough
for kids to focus in a physical
classroom
now you expect them to focus and learn
by sitting in a chair for hours a day
watching a talking head lecture them
over video
again the idea is absurd you cannot
replace in-person learning with videos
kids are human beings not robots
if we care about educating our children
we'll teach them
in person that's what they need and
deserve and that's what any good teacher
would be wanting and urging
that we do all right let's go to five
headlines
[Music]
and we're about to run through a bunch
of headlines remember you know there's
there's so much going on in the world
and so much to keep track of
you got to get a reader's pass at
dailywire.com that's going to keep you
up to date on all the stories and news
and everything
i get a reader's pass today from
dailywire.com to get exclusive op-eds
from
me and from the other podcast hosts as
well as guest writers in-depth analysis
from our daily wire reporters on top of
our regular breaking news
this membership tier is already a
bargain at three bucks a month but if
you join today you're gonna get your
first month for 99 cents you get access
to our mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news
special content as well as um the
community of daily wire members who are
actively commenting and discussing our
content so again dailywire.com
subscribe here's a good place to start
nice transition two women have been
arrested for assaulting a democratic
state senator in wisconsin
they went to the protest i think it was
in milwaukee
the senator was there taking pictures
this is a democrat
and they run up and assault him for no
reason they just assault him
here are the mugshots of these lovely
ladies you can take a look there
sameth samantha r hamer and karita e
o'reilly now here comes the twist ending
one of these women is a teacher can you
guess which one
if you guess the green green-haired one
well
nice guess and i wish you were right
because that would be just perfect
for what we're talking about but no
actually the blonde chick is the teacher
um
but either way not just a teacher okay
she's a
a school social worker who specializes
in working with kids with emotional
needs and behavioral issues
this is someone who's supposed to be
helping children
with emotional needs and behavioral
issues who is out in the street
assaulting state senators
number two let's um let's stay here on
the subject of lovely ladies at blm
protests here's a portland mom
offering a rather loud and unsolicited
explanation as to why
she is out protesting watch this
i'm so tired of it i am so
tired i am sleep deprived because i'm a
single mom
and i work full time and i have to come
and spend my nights with you
because i can't stand in my own streets
and say black lives matter
black lives matter that's why we're here
we're not here because of some
building we don't care about the
building we don't care about your stupid
fence
we care about black lives
and i'm a mom and i heard george when he
called out mama
that's why i'm here that's why i'm here
because george called out for his mama
you all have moms your mom
loves you george's mom loved you and my
kids love me and i want to go
home to them but they agree that this is
important
and it's not about some white ladies
it's not about me it's about black lives
matter
there are so many amazing black women
who've been doing this
fight for years and i showed up late i'm
so tardy to this party
but i'm making up for it because i'm so
angry
so angry and black black people are
allowed to be angry and
who cares that somebody graffiti's on
this stupid building we're talking about
human lives
of course none of what she's saying
there makes any sense whatsoever
it was a stirring monologue i'll give
her that very well rehearsed
um and so i give her credit for that but
she says she can't stand in the street
and shout black lives matter
meanwhile that's exactly what she's
doing
she's she's standing in the street
shouting about how she can't shout
i can't shout black lives matter i'm not
allowed to do what i'm doing right now
this is outrageous i can't do the thing
that i'm doing
um and you know in fact not only can you
stand in the street and shot black lives
matter but
in many cases you can commit felonies
and as long as you shout black lives
matter while you do it
you're not going to be arrested so this
is another protester who just
has imagined a form of oppression in her
head she has fabricated it like science
fiction
just make believe and she's out
protesting
against the oppression that she made up
in her head
and the whole bit about you know george
floyd crying out for his mama and she's
there for george
uh you know i'm sorry call me cynical i
i just don't buy the performative tiers
for george floyd at this point i i don't
buy it
i'm sorry i two months later and and
you're still overcome with grief in
tears
no there's quite a lot of death and
murder in the streets of portland or any
other city every day
has this woman cried tears for them i
mean you you're apparently so
empathetic that this one person you
don't know dies
two months later you're still not over i
mean two months later you're still in
tears literally breaking down weeping in
the street
well so with all of that overwhelming
exuding empathy do you what about all
the other death is it
does that i mean do you walk through
your day every day just overcome with
tears
at death and murder or is it just this
one particular
death that upsets you so much and not
all the others
we talked about brittany hill yesterday
young mother gunned down by chicago gang
members while holding her one-year-old
daughter
her daughter cried out for mama what
about that
why isn't this woman breaking down
publicly in tears over that
i mean is it because her tears
um only come out
in politically and ideologically
expedient moments is that why
number three here's some good news okay
let's too much bad news let's get to
some good news
all of that chronovirus cash was handed
out you know loans and stimuluses from
the government
and if you're wondering whatever
happened to that don't worry it was put
to good use
david t hines of miami obtained nearly 4
million in loans
and went out and bought a lamborghini uh
there's a
the car right there not a bad not a bad
vehicle
um not as nice as what i drive you know
i mean it's a little bit it's a few
steps down
by for my taste anyway but here's here's
clickorlando.com reporting says a south
florida man fraudulently obtained 3.9
million dollars in federal chronovirus
relief loans
using money uh some of the money to buy
a 318 000
lamborghini prosecutors say david d
hines was arrested and charged last week
with bank fraud making false statements
to financial institutions and engaging
in transactions
defense attorney chad petrowski
said heinz is a legitimate business
owner who is anxious to tell
his side of the story he's he's got his
side of the it's not what it looks like
all right
like i know it looks bad right now i've
got a 319 000
car that i bought with chronovirus loans
i know it looks bad i know how this
looks
got a good explanation i'm uh i'm i'm
anxious to hear what it is i
we we're not provided the explanation
but now it's kind of a cliffhanger we'll
have to check back i guess i'll keep
updating us on this story
uh let's go to the ap joe biden
yesterday was photographed holding his
notes um for remarks he was given and
he was giving remarks and he had notes
and the ap got a good
a good view of his notes let's look at
this picture there
um okay his his handwriting is almost
worse than mine
and my eyesight isn't very good so let
me see if i can um
okay it says camilla harris
do not hold the grudges
is that so is he is he
listing good things about her um
campaigned with me and jill
talent does that say talented talented
i can't tell what that says hold on
talented great help to
campaign great respect for her how does
he every
i had this problem with my own notes
when i write notes for myself and i
i can't tell it's like a foreign
language i can't read my own handwriting
i go back and try to
i have to decipher i have to call in you
know like an egyptian
egyptologist are they the ones that
decipher hieroglyphics anyway
um uh i'm just trying to figure out so
he's he's listing good things of oris
he's saying
camila harris do not hold like he's
telling himself not to hold grudges
against her
are these these are reminders to himself
about what he should think about her is
that what this is
it's remind you ever seen that movie
memento with um
you know where the main character has uh
he he's a he has no memory so he forgets
things after
40 seconds he has to he has to write all
these notes he actually tattoos them on
himself
just to tell him what he should be
thinking and feeling kind of reminds me
of that
all right number five finally very
important report here in the daily mail
listen to this it says women across the
country
are reporting a rise in aggressive eye
contact
since the introduction of face coverings
in some public places
new laws introduced over the weekend
force customers to wear face masks and
all shop stations banks and post offices
while it was also mandatory to wear
coverings on public transport but many
women have been sharing stories online
of aggressive eye contact
and quote hard staring from men wearing
masks
with one tweeting grown men staring at
you with a mask on is worse than when
they don't have a mask
u.n women uk executive director claire
burnett uh or barnett told
female that's with f-e-m-a-i-l
uh said as we work to build back
better following lockdowns we need to
prevent the lack of witness of
anti-social behavior due to less
populated public spaces
as well as the anonymity face coverings
can provide leading to further rises in
harassment and threatening actions
towards women girls and minoritized
groups
uh this will require widespread changes
in attitudes behaviors
uh creating an understanding that
behavior like unwanted and persistent
staring is intimidating
that we will have a role to play in
making our public spaces more
inclusive okay so this is someone from
the un
[Music]
who is set on the task of dealing with
the problem of aggressive eye contact i
i don't even what is a how can you make
eye contact aggressively
hard staring i don't even know what that
is
but either way this once again we have
the feminists
strong independent women who are
traumatized by aggressive eye contact
sure that's feminism for you
all right we're going to move on to our
daily cancellation but first
if you haven't picked up ben shapiro's
new book you got to do that his new book
out called how to destroy america in
three easy steps he did a live signing
last tuesday
and i think his hand might be broken
because he's only signing you know he's
signing copies today and tomorrow
so if you want to get a signed copy um
there might not be
many chances left to do it get your copy
now at dailywire.com
ben okay now for our daily cancellation
speaking of aggressive we are going to
cancel aggressively
and with great wrath and vengeance
everyone
who is pushing the police are kidnapping
people narrative
now we know this started in portland
when uniformed police officers were seen
arresting someone and putting them in an
unmarked vehicle
this is something that has happened
countless times over many decades it is
very normal um there is
nothing unique or new about it but
suddenly somehow for some reason
it's a scandal you know it's a it's a
it's a horrible thing that's happening
where
we're you know arresting people in
unmarked vehicles so here's the latest
now a video
of someone being arrested by nypd has
gone viral and has the left to include
people like chris
hayes and jerry nadler very very upset
about this video just uh we'll play it
right now watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
there is nothing strange or upsetting or
disturbing about what you just saw it's
an arrest
that's all yes the person being arrested
doesn't want to be
but that's pretty typical of arrests the
only other option aside from arresting
people like that is
is is to do it consensually and and this
appears to be what the left has in mind
you know this is the way they think
arrests should go now the officer should
walk up i guess
very very politely and say excuse me but
i noticed you committing a series of
felonies would you mind if i arrested
you for that
i mean you see we have these things
called laws and typically we what was
that oh you don't you don't want to be
arrested you know
oh well okay i had no idea so sorry to
bother you please please continue
here is this you're about to throw a
rock at a cop car right well here you go
here's the rock right back well
um please please proceed sorry to
interrupt
have a great day sir now i wish i was
joking that that is really what they
want
um many left this in response to this
video
have declared that the arrest was
unjustified
how could they possibly know that from
that footage it seems like they just
have a problem with arrests
in general how can you see a video of
someone being arrested
no context no footage of what transpired
before it
and just know automatically that the
person is innocent
you don't even know what they're accused
of doing i don't know what this person
is accused of doing or
why they're being arrested but they're
innocent take me seriously
it doesn't make any sense um
if you know minor details like facts
matter
i'll tell you what they're arrested for
the nypd has
explained it here's nypd news on twitter
explaining they've got they put out a
series of tweets
says in regard to a video on social
media that took place at
2nd avenue and 25th street a woman taken
into custody in an unmarked van
was wanted for damaging police cameras
during five separate criminal incidents
in and around city hall
the arresting officers were assaulted
with rocks and bottles
when officers from warrant squad took
the woman into custody in a gray nypd
minivan
this evening they were assaulted with
rocks and bottles the warren squad used
unmarked
vehicles to effectively locate wanted
suspects
uh which which makes a lot of sense it
makes sense to use them for that reason
they continue when she was placed in the
warren squad's unmarked gray
minivan it was behind a cordon cordon of
uh nypd bicycle cops in bright yellow
and blue uniform shirts
there to help affect the arrest
um makes sense to me
nonetheless people like chris hayes as
you can see here
say this is kidnapping this is dot dot
dot
kidnapping very very dramatic
no chris this is not kidnapping
this is making an arrest that's what it
looks like
sorry to scandalize you you hysterical
child
oh they're using unmarked vans the vans
are unmarked
so why does that matter i say
again there is nothing strange new or
scary about unmarked cop cars
police have been using unmarked cop cars
for decades they use them as was just
explained because sometimes the cops
don't want criminals to know they're
coming this is not a scandal
this isn't anything it's just normal
stuff
very normal stuff um
now we have here's what jerry nadler a
giant potato come to life that's my
theory anyway on jerry nadler
here's what he has to say about this he
sent out a tweet
this video of a protester in new york
city being thrown in unmarked van is
terrifying and should be unacceptable to
everyone who respects the constitutional
rights
this country was founded on um
there must be an immediate explanation
for this anonymous use of force
anonymous anonymous
they have bright neon uniforms that say
police on them
you potato this is what we get for
electing potatoes to
public office i've always said we
shouldn't you know we should stick with
with you know non-potatoes at least
nadler says he's terrified
terrified of the concept of police
making lawful arrests and putting
suspects into unmarked vehicles
which they've done millions of times
since the investment of the automobile
did nadler just start being terrified by
this now or has he always been terrified
of unmarked police cars
why didn't he say anything earlier he
could have got some medication or
something
he's driving down the road he's an
unmarked cop car at a you know
doing traffic stops does he break down
in tears
petrified so just to review here it is
not illegal for cops to use unmarked
vehicles
they do it all the time it makes sense
to use them because oftentimes criminals
don't want to be arrested and will run
away if you announce your arrival
and in fact despite claims to the
contrary it actually doesn't matter
if criminals don't want to be arrested
they can still be arrested
even if they don't want to be and it's
not kidnapping
because police have arresting powers
and that's why everyone complaining
about this is cancelled
and they're all potatoes all of them
potatoes are cancelled too
just for the record just to cover all
the bases
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clayton
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clinton